fledermäuse als brutstätten für turbo
viren diese tiere dienten den wirren der
ebola erkrankung saß und auch dem neuen
bewohner virus saß kopf zwei als reserve
wird eine aktuelle studie aus den usa
deckt jetzt auf dass die fledermäuse
selbst durch eine doppelte
abwehrstrategie gesund bleiben das
fatale dabei ist dass sich so turbo
viren entwickeln können und die sind für
uns menschen wirklich hochgefährlich
klicks um science-fiction hier gibt es
die spannende science videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
dann verpasst er nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen
die infektionskrankheit sars schweres
akutes respiratorischen syndrom gilt als
die erste pandemie des 21 jahrhunderts
gen analysen offenbarten dass das
verantwortliche corona virus
ursprünglich von fledermäusen stammte
und es dann wohl über speichel oder kot
auf wilde schleichkatzen übergegangen
war diese wurden in südchina von
menschen verzehrt die erreger haben es
also geschafft dann die art schranke vom
tier zum menschen zu überwinden ähnlich
wie bei der jetzigen corona virus
epidemie die es in sich hat die zahl der
ansteckungen und toten steigt weiter an
seit dem wochenende vor allem außerhalb
von china in südkorea italien iran und
jetzt auch in deutschland nach angaben
der gesundheitskommission sind
mittlerweile rund 90.000 menschen
weltweit infiziert die neuartige
lungenkrankheit cupid 19 hat mehr als
3000 menschen das leben gekostet viele
solcher merching dieses springen also
von tieren auf uns menschen über als
risiko tiere gelten vor allem die
fledermäuse nicht nur für die erreger
von saß sondern auch die des ebola-virus
des marburg virus und des nizza virus
dienten fledermäuse als ursprüngliches
reserve aber auch andere säugetiere wie
nager beherbergen große anteile an
zwischen viren ein us forschungsteam hat
jetzt genauer analysiert warum so viele
gefährliche viren ursprünglich aus
fledermäusen stammen demnach besitzen
die tiere ein besonderes immunsystem das
dafür sorgt dass solche infekte sehr
effektiv unterdrückt werden doch die
folgen sind fatal denn die viren rüsten
auf und entwickeln sich zu turbo viren
sie dann auf menschen übergehen hat
unsere abwehr schlechte chancen bei den
fledermäusen dagegen sieht das ganz
anders aussieht zeigen sich als äußerst
resistent die tiere können die viren in
sich tragen ohne dass sie selbst krank
erscheint dabei handelt es sich oft um
besonders vermehrungsfähige und
aggressive während ein großes rätsel für
die wissenschaft für die experimente
nutzten die us fachleute fledermaus
zellkulturen des schwarzen flug hundes
und des nilflughunde es diese
infizierten sie mit viren die den ebola
und marburg viren sehr ähnlich sind wie
kontroll kultur dieser untersuchung
bestand aus zellen der grünen mehr katz
also affen 10
diese hatten keine chance gegen die
viren und starben innerhalb weniger tage
ab das ergebnis bei den fledermaus
kulturen dagegen war ein völlig anderes
zahlreiche zellen waren zwar infiziert
doch die infektion verlief langsam
einige der zellen konnten sich sogar
gegen den angriff der viren wehren und
hielten ihnen stand sie blieben auch
nach mehreren tagen gesund dazu kam bog
von der university of california in
berkeley
das ist wie bei einem feuer das sich
durch einen wald brennt einige bäume
hier fledermaus zellen haben schutz
decken so dass das feuer vorbeirast ohne
ihnen zu schaden
doch um bei dieser metapher zu bleiben
es bleiben glühende kohlen liegen und
die sind jederzeit in der lage ein neues
voll feuer zu entfachen gemeint sind
damit die zellen in der kultur die
aktivieren enthalten wie das
forschungsteam herausfahren verfügen die
fledermäuse selbst über eine doppelte
abwehrstrategie sobald die abwehr der
tiere das erste mal mit den wehren in
kontakt kommt wird der botenstoff
interferon alpha ausgeschüttet und die
zelluläre abwehr sorgt dafür dass die
erreger abgeschottet werden
die krankheitssymptome werden
abgemildert und eine entzündungsreaktion
wird verhindert möglich wird das durch
den sehr aktiven stoffwechsel der
fledermäuse den sie für das fliegen
benötigen diese extreme
entzündungshemmende immunantwort fehlt
bei den meisten säugetieren die nicht
fliegen können und auch wir menschen
verfügen nicht über diese strategie dazu
die beteiligte forscherin karabag würde
unsere immunabwehr die gleiche
antivirale strategie versuchen würde
dies eine systemweite entzündung
auslösen
das immunsystem der fledermäuse aber ist
sehr hoch reguliert denn durch den
aktiven stoffwechsel entstehen
zahlreiche entzündungs auslösende stoffe
gegen diese muss der körper der tiere
sehr effektiv angehen und so ist ihr
immunsystem in der lage sehr effektiv
und hartnäckig gegen aggressive erreger
vorzugehen das ist natürlich eine schöne
sache für die tiere selbst doch dadurch
entstehen hochgefährliche und tödliche
turbo viren dazu heißt es von dem
autorenteam wenn man eine starke
immunantwort hat und einige zellen vor
der infektion geschützt sind dann kann
das virus seine vermehrung hoch
regulieren ohne dass sein wird stirbt
unsere studien demonstriert wie das
immunsystem der fledermäuse die virulenz
solcher erreger ankurbeln kann
sobald diese turbinen auf andere tiere
oder uns menschen überspringen haben sie
leichtes spiel denn dann treffen sie auf
immunsysteme die denen der fledermäuse
weit unterlegen sind und dem turbo virus
kein paroli bieten können fachleute
betonen dass diese erkenntnisse keinen
grund sei weder mäuse zu bekämpfen denn
wenn wir menschen abstand halten würden
seien auch virus ausbrüche vermeidbar
demnach sei es wichtig die natürlichen
lebensräumen der fledermäuse zu schützen
und zu bewahren denn nur so können
krankheitsausbrüche verhindert werden
die infektionen passieren beispielsweise
bei der jagd auf wildtiere und in der
nutztierhaltung heißt also wir menschen
selbst sind oft dafür verantwortlich
dass neue kontakte zwischen tieren und
menschen entstehen in dem der wälder
roden und ihn zuvor unberührten regionen
einbringen das bietet den erregern dann
die chance zum überspringen auf die
menschlichen population corona virus
woher kommt es da erklärt ein fach
medizin noch einmal exakt die herkunft
dieses konkreten virus also anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren und zwar
einfach medizin niederlage neuer kanal
die nicht nur empfehlen kann bis dann
bleib dran